[MUSIC PLAYING]
PRADEEP NALLURI: Mutual
Mobile is a digital technology
agency where we counsel Fortune
500 companies to startups.
Culture is like a
personality of the company.
When we hire people, they're
not just technologists,
they also have other
facets in their life.
My name is Pradeep Nalluri,
and I am general manager
at Mutual Mobile.
For me, a great product is
an intersection between art,
humanities, and technology.
MUSTAFA ALI: My
name is Mustafa Ali.
I am the director of
technology at Mutual Mobile.
We were one of the first
companies in the world
to have cross-functional teams
where you have engineers,
designers, project managers,
product owners, quality
assurance engineers all working
together to deliver a product.
SAM SOLOMON: My
name is Sam, and I'm
an engineer at Mutual Mobile.
When we first started working
with the Google Developers
Agency Program, it was
for me one of the biggest
things that we could do.
We have Hangouts On Air,
we have several tech
sessions, knowledge transfer
sessions that Google
is providing to us.
We got early access to a
host of Firebase's tools.
This allowed us to offer
things to our clients that
were far beyond the scope
of what they could normally
achieve with any other agency.
SPANDANA BATCHU: While working
with Bass Forecast, the product
that we were using,
was announced
to be shutting down soon,
and we were all freaking out.
And thanks to Developer
Agency Program,
we had access to Firebase
even before it was publicly
announced, and we were
able to quickly switch
to Firebase and deliver
the product on time.
SAM SOLOMON: We did run into
some issues here and there.
We needed a couple
of things to be
fixed so that we could continue
with our process as well.
Having the privilege
of being a partner
has allowed us to get
those features in place.
MUSTAFA ALI: Good thing about
the Early Access Program
was that it was a
two-way relationship.
We got early access to
products, and, in turn,
we could give feedback,
report bugs, and help
make the product better.
PRADEEP NALLURI: We
are in the business
of selling our people's time.
By actually having that
relationship with Google,
our employees are
constantly getting
the leading-edge
technology, information,
they're getting trained by
the best Google developers.
SAM SOLOMON: It is a force
that drives us to be better
engineers every single day.
[MUSIC PLAYING]